thousands of migrants from central
america are gathering in guatemala for
an expected
push north towards the united states
mexican border forces are alert for
their arrival
it's thought the migrants are hoping joe
biden's incoming administration will be
less
tough on migration than the current one
determined not to stop till they reach
the u.s
this group of several thousand honduran
migrants now in guatemala
have been walking for weeks
some of them clashed with guatemalan
police as authorities tried to push them
back towards the border
but with little effect
[Applause]
escaping an economy battered by the
pandemic
gang violence and hurricanes they are
seeking a better life
in the north
we are going after the american dream
because in our country
there's no jobs there's a lot of crime
and you cannot make a living
our house was swept away by hurricanes
with a new u.s administration being
sworn in next week
and joe biden promising a more humane
approach to immigration these travelers
are hopeful first i'll find a job in the
us
we think about our families and want to
help those
who helped us
mexican authorities have deployed 500
officers to the border
an agreement with the u.s stops them
letting migrants through
but like so many before them the people
here see no alternative
but to keep pushing on